all right we all gotta do it together we
all gotta do together one two three
hello
rejection
john you messed it up what's what was he
gonna say what is it
i thought it was what's your favorite
we've rehearsed before him why do you
think we're never on the same page we
said hello hello guys we're here at
cinemark today so yeah we just saw the
new scream movie at cinemark and it's
really great to be here i mean this
sincerely because i rewatched all the
scream movies over the past week and
scream is my favorite horror movie
franchise i've said that so many times
to be at the theaters and i've only seen
one scream movie in the theaters which
was screen four to be back i'm like wow
we're watching scream on the big screen
so if you guys are interested in
checking this movie out it is the way to
experience it with the sound design the
scope it's really awesome experience so
thank you cinemark for having us here
this movie to me you know as much as we
talk about like comic book movies and
all that this is actually one of my most
anticipated movies you guys have no idea
how much i've like dissected this and
been like i really really really want to
see this movie so there's a lot to talk
about with this film you know obviously
it's a scream movie so we gotta talk
about the meta commentary we gotta talk
about the kills we gotta talk about
legacy characters returning we gotta
talk about the new characters we gotta
talk about how we feel overall about the
structure of the plot some twists and
turns without spoiling anything which is
gonna be really challenging but i'm
gonna be very careful about that because
literally in the first like 15 to 20
minutes of this movie there was a moment
that happened i'm like oh oh [ __ ]
like we're already here we're already in
spoiler territory
this is spoilery right here movie yeah
what are you doing see it quickly
because you don't want to know anything
i stopped watching trailers i wanted to
experience this i would recommend seeing
it as quickly as possible because it's a
whodunit you wanna who done it i think
what this movie did an exceptional job
at doing was really making it not feel
like a cash grab of course it has the
self-awareness but they do such a great
job at the meta commentary justifying
its existence here and honestly with the
way they do the like the handling of the
commentary this franchise has been wes
craven's franchise and kevin williamson
as well and i think they'd be really
proud of the way they handled the
commentary and intersecting that with
its characters as well with the whodunit
i feel like this is a movie that exists
in a world of commentary because the
first scream was very inventive in the
fact that it was a commentary on other
horror films while actively being a
horror film but we as a society has
progressed in large part thanks to
scream in a lot of circles in that vein
so whereas recent franchises may have
added a meta-modernistic take on
in-fiction commentary and it not quite
feeling as good this having a
meta-modernistic take in commentary
works because those movies dealt with
meta modernism in regards to reality
this movie deals with meta modernism in
regard to in-universe reality so whereas
scream has its series of rules these
rules are built on those rules which
allows a legacy and it also allows us to
kind of have like the deadpool joke like
fourth wall break on fourth wall break
16 walls this is an evolution of
metamodernistic commentary in a really
lovely way like i know stream four was
dealing with it this does it much better
dealing with soft reboots dealing with
request the way they handle that
commentary i was i was really impressed
by it
this is funny and the way it's it's
being uh mirrored in the movie is really
well done but john what did you think
about the movie i liked it overall it
isn't a perfect ride but i think the
things that are the most important for a
large part it does get right it's a
pretty pretty br not maybe the most
brutal but it feels verbal in the way
that it's captured just the amount of
like stabs they're allowed to include
and it's more intimate it's more like
there's something that's going to kill
there's something to the methodical
there's something to the way that shot
like i love the directing of this film
and i really appreciate the fact that
they let you kind of breathe in moments
that i think other installments didn't
yeah i think it gets brutal with the
kills but not in the way of like
halloween kills does it where i'm like
now this is just disturbing and i'm not
having fun anymore while being much more
brutal than i usually enjoy i'm so
invested in the characters and the humor
and everything else it hurts more but i
like it as opposed to certain horror
movies where i'm like bro why am i here
like i'm just like upset like it's time
yes this was nice you were telling me
about it like what the kills of the way
they stab here it's it it becomes
comical in the way how it progresses in
the franchise where it's like this guy's
just becoming a superhuman or a
girl but depending on which movie you're
watching right here i'm like this feels
like a prison fight yeah yeah it's
really scrappy and very tangible and one
thing that they do i think excel at as
well in this movie is letting the victim
characters fight back in ways that feel
for the most part pretty plausible and
that's what i've always enjoyed about
scream is you've got your jason voorhees
and your mike myers who are like these
unstoppable forces you don't have that
same fear whereas this like scream gets
knocked down and it gets up again you're
never going to keep them down
pissing the night away my main qualms
with this will actually come down to
i'll save it in a second all right
but john who would you say out of the
legacy returning characters obviously
we've seen divorce couple courtney cox
and david arquette coming back here but
there are good terms as you can tell in
interviews i really get the sets like
you guys are in really good terms i'm
really happy you're one of the best
divorce couples i've ever seen
divorce goals
[Laughter]
hey that's a very realistic thing now
51 but in terms of the legacy characters
john who i think all the certain grants
of this who would you say the highlight
is oh it's got to be david arquette
surprise of all surprises he really
showed up for this movie and he was one
of the most touching and most you know
investible characters in the way that
the movie adds flesh to him and treats
him a little less like a joke like
acknowledges the kind of doofy aspects
of dewey but at the same time it gives
him a little more credence than before
which was nice yeah i was really
surprised by that because like dewey i
mean it's always like sydney and dewey
they're my favorites right dewey in this
one i was like wow david our cat's
really going for like that he's really
got the pathos here and then what they
set up his character i don't want to
ruin it you expect a very like cliche
thing that they would do between him and
gayle but they give a much richer
complexity he's written like a person
he's not written like well even the
relationship is written like there's a
gray area yeah probably based off of the
real life courtney cox of david you also
feel the passage of time with this
character really beautifully like
there's an old man dewey there's an old
man or cat to it all which i really
enjoyed but between the legacy
characters to me sydney prescott the
scream franchise has always been sidney
prescott like nev campbell it like is
phenomenal to me and pretty much like
three out of four of these movies like
she's still really great and scream
three i just don't like the writing of
that movie so much never campbell's
always been phenomenal has really
carried this franchise as the lead
character and it's always tied back in
with her and this is the one that's
definitely the least about her you know
nev campbell's fine in this movie that's
all i'll say like i honestly ended up
being like i like her here because i
[ __ ] love neff campbell and sydney
prescott's my favorite but when i look
back on this film i go i feel like they
could have really done this without her
i feel like like she maybe like a cameo
was fine but i don't feel like she was
ultimately necessary to be in this movie
without giving anything away which i
can't there is things that i think like
in a spoiler review were necessary but i
also understand where you're coming from
and i think that's the difference in our
experience i felt like they could have
given it to gail
i thought they were going to do that
yeah i mean having both gail and sydney
in this movie like it's very gratifying
i feel like everyone's trying to
recreate the wallop of jamie lee curtis
in halloween 2018 which even halloween
kills couldn't do and a lot of other
movies with these kinds of legacy
characters couldn't do and they don't
quite get their hair not that they're
even necessarily trying yeah and then
she's not i don't want to say she's bad
like by no stretch is she bad it just i
did feel like the legacy characters
other than dewey were kind of like well
we need them in here because you know
because they're going to be part of the
movie yeah
yeah yeah it's necessary we got to have
our lovely the characters that we love
so switch to the newer characters i feel
like of the four now five films i really
liked this match of the four sequels
like they really impressed me with the
immediate likability the charm the
overall gaggle of kids usually there's
like one or two that you're like this
time i was really invested in almost all
of them i was like oh what a charming
group of little troublemakers most of
this movie is focused on the new
characters but whereas the other ones
were really about like the legacy of
sydney prescott and her past and
resolving that and how it would tie back
in this is much more about new
characters and a lot of spoilery things
i can't get into there's this character
here god i i'm like i'm trying to think
of the trailer and how much they show so
i'm trying not to give it away just
don't look it up there's a character
named tara who's awesome in this movie
she's the best it might be tara is my
favorite probably the best new
character we should just leave
in here very very believable and then
the other characters i think are are
likable and jack quaid is really good
and he's really funny he's really great
in this movie my main issue with this is
honestly the lead samantha whoever that
actress is and it pains me to say this
because this franchise has rested so
much on a powerful female character even
with the these directors doing ready or
not who created the samara weaving
character they know how to write
characters who are feeling weak and
vulnerable who have to arc into strength
the writing wasn't the best but really i
i genuinely feel like the her acting
wasn't that good early on in the movie
she has a monologue and it's a very
dramatic
hefty monologue and i really felt like i
was watching
a good audition yeah i was like aware
i didn't really feel
for her not every scene she has falls
flat for me but more often than not i
couldn't really couldn't believe her and
especially if you're stepping in for you
know after this
what nev campbell has done for four
movies not that they're you're going to
compare them they're very different
characters well it's the lightning in a
bottle of all these slasher franchises
that catch on is i think part of it or
or a strong element a lot of them share
is that yeah you have this lead who you
can endear very heavily to and fall in
love with and want to follow and root
for the lead in this i thought was was
decent was pretty good but it wasn't
enough to really fully invest me and
forget about the moviness of her
character for me the ensemble was strong
enough it didn't distract for me as much
but i definitely found myself being like
where's blank and it wasn't one blank it
was just enough blanks that i was like
oh that might be a flaw what they i
don't think they really managed to do in
terms of a requel was from the first
movie of scream
like even upon re-watching i'm like man
they really knocked it out of the park
with getting these characters like they
just nailed it like yeah man i am so
attached it's not a nostalgia thing it's
like no i just love them they're really
well done and i never quite felt that
here for anyone of like i like them but
that love didn't quite translate kind of
with terror though i had it for tara and
i i had it for jack quay but the fact
that i can't remember his name doesn't
bode well they were screamed one level
for me but it's not the six like scream
one really just how do you get that many
lightning strikes yeah like there were
so many characters that just stood out
but then again the movie has some great
commentary about that wood fandom then
i'm like crap i'm one of these fans are
talking about right now that's right hey
there are certain things that are going
to bite you on your way out of the
theater does some great things with
talking about toxic fandom and i found
myself like i'm not like that really
with like marvel or dc honestly or star
wars but when it became the scream i was
like oh [ __ ] they're kind of talking
about me
we all have a scream greg we all have a
screams guys yeah i did find myself
doing that you're the killer of this one
yeah there's some weird structure with
here where i like sorry to get into this
i was pointless there was never a scene
here
where i truly felt tense i was always
engaged but i never felt tension and i
felt that with stream one two and four
there's this great hospital scene in
here that you see teas in the trailers
and that scene like the way they execute
all those elements and a lot of
different physicality stuff they do like
some very different things we haven't
seen done in the screen movies yet i
love that sequence yet it was more from
like an observational aberrational uh
standpoint of like wow that's really
clever oh that's really cool but i was
never like
you know i was very tender i was very
tense for 90 of them were you i was
downright scared we're a little bit more
used to horror
so yeah so if you're like me and you
avoid this stuff generally i was like
i'm uncomfortable and like i'm aware of
that but also desensitization i yeah i
actually screamed at twice at two points
i i yelped some scenes fall a little too
soap opera for me that's a weird thing
to say because if you look at the other
screen movies like even scream one and
two there are like dramatic scenes but
they always felt like there was a life
about them sometimes i felt like the
energy of them would kind of really slow
down with some
soap opera sappiness and there's this
one specific choice with
you'll know it when you see it
you know how scream three had that thing
with like sydney's mom being a presence
they kind of do that with someone else
and it didn't quite work for me i think
my biggest flaw for talking negatives is
in the third act you've got uh you know
your traditional mystery solved the
moment worked for me enough but i
definitely feel like it didn't work for
me as well as other installments in this
franchise so i think my biggest issue is
i was along for the ride i was tense i
was laughing i was scared i was fully
invested and that moment wasn't like the
uh i needed it to be but that doesn't
drop it enough to be a lot less of a
movie it just kept it from that a it's
in that high b plus range for me because
of that with it being a scream movie
there's obviously going to be some
twists and turns and reveals along the
way some of it was well executed even if
it was predictable i was kind of
surprised by how a decent amount of it
even up until the end was surprisingly
predictable there was one big twist that
was teased a lot on social media that
you know while i didn't actually see it
coming it didn't quite click for me
fully here's the thing what i don't want
to miscommunicate because you guys have
seen us do enough talks by this point
where if i don't like something i'm
going to be very direct with you guys
and i really enjoyed this i i enjoyed it
a lot and this is a big mantle to take
up like this has been wes craven's
franchise you know and then very
specific characters and one thing that's
made of scream unique is that it's not
just having one character come back it's
been having three characters and the
presence of randy exists through the
franchise can't say that about many
horror franchises it's usually just like
the killer who's the standout so to take
on this mantle do something new do
something different i i really gotta
commend the directors and writers for
this because i think they knocked it out
of the park when you're dealing with
taking this on and this could have been
so much worse and then even like calling
it scream it hit me like 30 minutes in
with their commentary like they never
say it in the movie but i was like
that's why it's called scream yeah and
not scream five like they did such a
good job at justifying that because
that's always seem weird like why not
just call the stream five yeah and then
i'm watching i'm like oh
you seem to have a
what's this about scream yeah i
definitely recommend it and there's
plenty of fun to be had in here and yeah
i'd say like a good b plus to me i would
say like i saw that like 7.
five out of ten for me sure i'll go yeah
yeah i'm gonna go 8.2
a little more centered could be a little
more streamlined in certain ways or
maybe a little more fleshed but
ultimately it gets a lot of stuff right
yeah it's like i like it way more than
scream three it was so fun like i really
enjoyed the journey well that's our
thoughts on scream coming right out of
the theater it's hard not to spoil i've
been very tense this whole time last few
minutes i'm like i don't want to say
anything like communicating anything
here guys scream did you only watch the
first two minutes of this video whatever
screw you subscribe click that bell
thanks koi for being here watching the
equipment while we had to run the target
to get a tripod that's a true story made
a tick tock and uh
john i'm here see you guys soon thanks
to mark